so our first question is going to come
from sanjita patel from entertainment
tonight canada
it's wonderful to see you
congratulations to you i mean this is a
moment 20 nominations your first
nomination you're a writer we see hannah
winning are you taking all this in this
moment what ted lasso actually means to
so many people out there uh i mean i'm
struggling to take any of this in
because it's um so
surreal and uh
and also i didn't realize we were up so
quickly so i thought oh there'll be some
time to settle into the ceremony and
then they were singing and dancing and
suddenly they were calling our names i
was like what is going on
so
yeah maybe ask me in a week if i've made
sense of any of this
congratulations thank you sentient yeah
thank you sanjitsa next up andrew friend
from dishnation
fred uh congratulations first i want to
ask you what were you saying that we
could not hear
on stage what exactly were you saying oh
did they bleep it
oh yeah they bleeped you a good chunk oh
no really
oh
yeah
oh well i don't but
truthfully i don't know what i said uh
it's all a blur but i mean it was
probably swearing right i don't know how
much bleeping went up yeah yeah probably
how much did you hear you make a
i i no i heard a good chunk but then i
think you were swearing so they just
kind of took out the swears
but i want to know what do you make of
the success of the show and why it's not
just the us that's fallen in love with
the show it's the entire world yeah i
mean it's incredible look truthfully i
don't think any of us thought anyone
would watch it let alone like it let
alone all this
but i do think it sort of speaks to how
starved people were to see
sort of people trying to be better and
kinder and
you know i think i think it probably
speaks to that is why it sort of
resonated so much because it felt so
unusual it's like oh we needed this
you know it says more about what was
going on than necessarily what we were
doing you know
last question how will you celebrate
tonight are you going to party are you
going to drink kind of take me through
uh your night
uh
i i believe both of those things will be
happening
thank you andrew congratulations thanks
and next up we have libby hill from indy
wire
hey brett congratulations
hey how are you i don't know hey how are
you good to see you they told you not to
swear that's when you get bleeped when
you swear that's you know they kind of
laid it out all for you uh i have to ask
you know we famously heard you were cast
as roy kent after submitting your own
own submission tape um how do you feel
about that decision now as you stand
backstage at the emmys uh holding the
emmy for a supporting actor in a comedy
series
i feel like
i'm pretty glad i took the risk
uh
i feel i feel pretty glad i took the
risk
sure i'm glad i'm glad yeah
congratulations brett you are uh you're
a marvel thank you olivia nice to see
you thank you
nice to see you
yeah um i also want to welcome your
colleague hannah waddingham come on over
come join brett you both both have
matching pieces of hardware there
hello hello hello
hi there come in come in come in
it is it is
hello by the way everyone uh please
raise your hand if you have a question
that you would like to ask hannah or
brett and then we can get you in line we
can get you in line
hello hello okay excellent what we're
gonna do now is heather brooker from nbc
digital heather
question is all yours
hello hello congratulations you guys i'm
heather with nbc los angeles um we
absolutely love ted lasso we cannot wait
for every episode when it comes out
and um hannah i have to say i teared up
during your speech you were so emotional
um i also have a daughter i would love
to know
what
how you're going to talk to your
daughter about this does she know is she
watching and truly what this means for
you as a mom thank you for asking that
question because i was so overwhelmed if
i'd just sworn for a minute i wouldn't
have been surprised
my little girl and i have become such a
little unit because i am a single mom
and i just wanted to say to her that she
can have this in her bedroom to show her
that her mummy will only ever be away
when it's for a really blooming good
reason and i think it shows her that
you know
if when she's older she just has to
fight that little bit harder and magical
things happen
i love that i love that and last
question for you guys what is it about
this show that has resonated so much
with people around the world
see it's hard for him to answer this
because he's in the writers room and
they are all the most ridiculously
annoyingly modest people on the planet
you know they are for to be in both
camps i just i get a bit overwhelmed by
this one but i just think that
they
the people that are in that room the
chemistry in that room affords us to
have chemistry and it's like a perfect
alchemy
thank you so much heather and now our
final question this is going to be a
brief one by ali rosenblum with e news
hi congratulations
hannah
what did you think when seth rogen maybe
accidentally mispronounced your last
name oh i didn't hear that that's brand
new information to me he's dead uh what
did he say waddington i didn't i had to
be honest oh what did he say
waddington oh man
i'm gonna call him seth ragin
thank you thank you so much appreciate
you ali thank you everyone thank you
guys
[Music]
you